non
chères amies et chers collègues mesdames
et messieurs
je voudrais tout d'abord remercier le
président zemsky et à travers lui le
peuple ukrainien
jeu de nous accueillir aujourd'hui et
par notre présence
tous les quatre à kiev nous exprimons le
salut fraternel des peuples européens un
peuple libre et souverain dont
l'héroïsme face à l'agression armée de
la russie force
l'admiration
nourrie de respect et exige un clair
soutien
ce soutien vous l'avez monsieur le
président vous le savez vous pouvez
compter sur nous
l'ukraine peut compter sur nous l'europe
dès le premier jour de cette guerre a su
choisir avec clarté son camp celui d'une
ukraine libre et souveraine celui du
respect du droit international
de la défense des principes inscrits
dans la charte des nations unies que la
russie a fait le choix
prémédité délibéré
injustifiée et injustifiable
de violer
ce choix de la guerre de la destruction
et du chaos ce choix de l'agression
armée d'un pays souverain pour asservir
un peuple libre nous ne l'acceptons pas
et ne l'accepteront jamais
parlé sanction sans précédent que nous
avons adoptée par le soutien massif
économiques humanitaires
militaires que chacun de nos pays et
l'union européenne tout entière apporte
à l'ukraine et que nous allons encore
intensifiés
nous sommes et nous resterons dans la
durée à vos côtés pour défendre votre
souveraineté
votre intégrité territoriale et votre
liberté c'est notre objectif nous n'en
avons pas d'autres et nous n'atteindrons
aujourd'hui
c'est clairement sur le sol ukrainien
que se joue la sécurité du continent
européen dans son ensemble
c'est le premier message que je voulais
adresser aux côtés de mes homologues
l'europe est à vos côtés elle le restera
autant qu'il le faudra jusqu'à la
victoire qui aura le visage du retour de
la paix dans une ukraine libre et
indépendante le visage opposés
aux conséquences de la barbarie que nous
avons vus ensemble ce matin à irvine
nous avons ainsi
évoqué avec le président zelensky les
besoins immédiats dans les domaines
humanitaire économique et militaire
la france évidemment et restera au
rendez vous pour y répondre nous avons
d'ores et déjà mobilisé deux milliards
de dollars pour le soutien économique et
humanitaire et nous le consolideront
dans la durée tout comme nous
poursuivrons les livraisons de matériel
militaire
notamment les canons caesar qui
permettent aux soldats ukrainien de se
défendre plus efficacement face aux
attaques de l'armée russe sur le sol de
l'ukraine
la france depuis le premier jour a
scrupuleusement tenu ses engagements et
à chaque fois que j'ai pris un
engagement à votre endroit il a donné
lieu décision et à une mise en oeuvre
rapide car nous savons il faut du
matériel mais il le faut vite c'est
aussi pourquoi au delà des douze césars
d'ores et déjà livrés conformément à vos
demandes j'ai pris la décision pour que
dès les prochaines ce même si césar
additionnel puisse l'être
nous allons aussi poursuivre et
renforcer notre action pour que les
crimes de guerre commis sur le sol
ukrainien dans le monde entier a été le
témoin ne restent pas impunis et pour
que le droit et la justice
internationale s'impose
la france a très rapidement envoyés sur
les lieux de ces massacres une équipe de
spécialistes pour contribuer à la
collecte de preuves et permettre à la
justice de suivre son cours j'ai annoncé
tout à l'heure au président cnce qui la
fourniture prochaine d'un laboratoire
mobile d' analyse adn qui apportera une
aide importante dans ce difficile
travail
lutter contre toute forme d'impunité
d'autres pays européens se mobilisent
désormais pour assurer la poursuite de
ce travail indispensable et nous
soutenons les efforts de la cour pénale
internationale pour faire la lumière sur
les atrocités impardonnable commis en
ukraine
face au simulacre de procès qui rappelle
les heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire nous opposerons la rigueur et
la légitimité du droit
le deuxième sujet que nous avons abordés
ensemble est celui de la sécurité
alimentaire
la crise alimentaire mondiale que nous
traversons est une conséquence directe
de la guerre menée par la russie elle
n'a pas d'autre explication
il nous rappelle d'ailleurs que les
sanctions qui ont été successivement
prises par les européens ne touche pas
les produits agricoles bruts
contrairement à ce qui a souvent été dit
nous appelons donc solennellement
ensemble depuis kiev la russie membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité
a accepté que les nations unies
organisent l'exportation des céréales ce
qui nécessitent d'accepter
de lever le blocus des ports ukrainiens
par la marine russe est d'apporter
toutes les garanties de sécurité
pour l'ukraine afin de permettre
justement la sortie de ces céréales
nous avons ensemble confirmer notre
soutien à l'initiative dû secrétaire
général des nations unies notre
disponibilité à aider concrètement à sa
mise en oeuvre comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue italien à l'instant il faut
pour cela une résolution du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies à laquelle la
russie
s'est opposée
j'espère qu'elle changera rapidement
d'avis en parallèle je remercie nos
présidents lieu à nice pour son travail
nous oeuvrons pour que d'autres voies
puissent être suivis en particulier sur
le danube ou par la roumaine
nous avons enfin évoqué ensemble notre
volonté de confirmer par les actes au
delà des mots que l'ukraine fait partie
de la famille européenne
face à la guerre je le disais le soutien
des européens s'est imposé comme une
évidence
d'abord en quelque sorte tous vu perçu
mesurer la fragilité de la paix si
durement acquise après la seconde guerre
mondiale et dont le souvenir douloureux
est au coeur de l'histoire de la
construction européenne
cette guerre
changera l'histoire de l'europe nous
nous tiendrons aux côtés de l'ukraine
pour l'accompagner dans cette
perspective européenne comme nous
l'avons acté à 27 lors du sommet de
versailles et c'est bien ce que nous
avons ensemble confirmé au président
dans quelques jours dès demain la
commission européenne posera le cadre de
la discussion et des décisions majeures
seront prises la semaine prochaine à
bruxelles par le conseil tous les quatre
nous soutenons le statut de candidat
immédiat à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne pour l'ukraine ce statut sera
assorti nous l'avons dit tous ensemble
d'une feuille de route et impliquera
aussi que soit prise en compte la
situation des balkans occidentaux
et du voisinage en particulier de la
moldavie nous aurons dans les prochains
jours à bâtir ensemble
l'unanimité des 27 pour ce conseil
européen si important
mais à travers notre visite
les échanges que nous avons eus cette
expression claire c'est un geste fort
rapide attendue
d'espoir et de clarté que nous voulons
envoyer à l'ukraine et à son peuple